putting together a probabilistic model
that is a model of a random phenomenon
or a random experiment involves two
steps first step we describe the
possible outcomes of the phenomenon or
experiment of interest second step we
describe our beliefs about the
likelihood of the different possible
outcomes by specifying a probability law
here we start by just talking about the
first step namely the description of the
possible outcomes of the experiment so
we carry out an experiment for example
we flip a coin or maybe we flip five
coins simultaneously or maybe we roll a
die whatever that experiment is it has a
number of possible outcomes and we start
by making a list of the possible
outcomes or a better word instead of the
word list is to use the word set which
has a more formal mathematical meaning
so we create a set that we usually
denote by capital Omega that set is
called the sample space and is the set
of all possible outcomes of our
experiment the elements of that set
should have certain properties namely
the elements should be mutually
exclusive and collectively exhaustive
what does that mean mutually exclusive
means that if at the end of the
experiment I tell you that this outcome
happened then it should not be possible
that this outcome also happened at the
end of the experiment there can only be
one of the outcomes that has happened
being collectively exhaustive means
something else that together all these
elements of the set exhausts all the
possibilities so no matter what at the
end you will be able to point to one of
the outcomes and say that's the one that
occurred to summarize this set should be
such that at the end of the experiment
you
should be always able to point to one
and exactly one of the possible outcomes
and say that this is the outcome that's
occurred physically different outcomes
should be distinguished in the sample
space and correspond to distinct points
but when we say physically different
outcomes what do we mean we really mean
different in all relevant aspects but
perhaps not different in irrelevant
aspects let's make more precise what I
mean by that by looking at a very simple
and maybe silly example which is the
following suppose that you flip a coin
and you see whether it resulted in heads
or tails so you have a perfectly
legitimate sample space for this
experiment which consists of just two
points heads and tails together these
two outcomes exhaust all possibilities
and the two outcomes are mutually
exclusive so this is a very legitimate
sample space for this experiment now
suppose that while you were flipping the
coin you also looked outside to the
window to check the weather and then you
could say that my sample space is really
heads and it's raining another possible
outcome is heads and no rain another
possible outcome is tails and it's and
it's raining and finally another
possible outcome is tails and no rain
this set consisting of four elements is
also a perfectly legitimate sample space
for the experiment of flipping a coin
the elements of this sample space are
mutually exclusive and collectively
exhaustive exactly one of these outcomes
is going to be true or will have
materialized at the end of the X
so which sample space is the correct one
this sample space the second one
involves some irrelevant details so the
preferred sample space for describing
the caught the flipping of a coin the
preferred sample space is the simpler
one the first one which is sort of at
the right granularity given what were
interested in but ultimately the
question of which one is the right
sample space depends on what kind of
questions you want to answer for example
if you have a theory that the weather
effects the behavior of coins then in
order to play with that theory or maybe
check it out and so on then in such a
case you might want to work with the
second sample space this is a common
feature in all of science whenever you
put together a model you need to decide
how detailed you want your model to be
and the right level of detail is the one
that captures those aspects that are
relevant and of interest to you